━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
内藤忍の資産デザイン研究所メール＜第七百二号2026年9月18日（金）発行＞
資産デザイン研究所メールは、資産運用に役立つ情報を個人投資家の皆様に提供するウィークリー・メールマガジンです。
金融資産だけではなく、不動産をはじめとする実物資産への投資まで、幅広い投資対象を組み合わせる「ハイブリッド投資」の具体的方法を可能な限り客観的な視点でご紹介いたします。
資産デザイン研究所
内藤忍公式ブログ
内藤忍、株式会社資産デザイン研究所は、資産配分などの投資アドバイスは行いますが、金融商品の勧誘・推奨などの投資助言業務は一切行っておりません。
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
将来のお金の不安を解消したい方のための資産設計実践会セミナー＆説明会のご案内
内藤忍が主宰し開講から12年目を迎える資産設計実践会
インナーサークル情報を活用して個人投資家のお金の不安を解消するためのコンテンツを提供
金融資産、国内外の不動産、不動産以外の実物資産、暗号資産や節税戦略まで
200名近いメンバーが集まる投資家コミュニティに興味がある方は、まずはセミナー＆説明会にご参加ください
詳しい内容とセミナー＆説明会への参加申し込みはこちらから
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
1　資産デザインのすすめ　〜　こんしゅうの気になるテーマ
2　本気でやる資産運用　〜　セミナー・勉強会のお知らせ
3　読者の質問コーナー
4　内藤忍の「白米ダイエット日記」
5　資産運用日記
6　内藤忍のつぶやき
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
＜内藤忍の公式ブログ Shinoby`s World コラムタイトル一覧＞
毎日更新している公式ブログの、前回メールマガジン配信以降のコラムです。
こちらから全文をお読みいただけます
9月12日 海外旅行は工夫次第で安くできる
9月13日 健康診断の前は「節制」より「暴飲暴食」した方が良い
9月14日 犬を飼うと長生きするというのは本当か？
9月15日 テスラの新型ロードスターへの「期待と不安」
9月16日 アクティブファンドで金融機関の「カモ」になっている人
9月17日 東京の名店が次々と消えていく理由
9月18日 新聞には中古品買取業者の折り込みだらけ
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
＜内藤忍のメディア出演・出版情報＞
【毎月更新】マネックス証券の投資情報サイト「マネクリ」
最新コラムタイトルは
「これから住むべき場所はどう決める？
」
連載一覧はこちらから
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
1　資産デザインのすすめ〜こんしゅうの気になるテーマ
「円安・インフレ」に突き進む高市政権
高市首相は内閣改造を行い引き続き「責任ある積極財政」を掲げる新体制が動き出しました。
その政策がもたらすのは最終的にインフレと円安の加速ではないかと思います。
財源の手当ての無いままの食料品のしょうひ税引き下げと防衛予算の大幅拡大が同時に進めば、財政収支の悪化は避けられません。
歳入よりも歳出が膨らむ財政構造は国債の発行増加を招き、日本の財政規律に対するしじょうの不信感を一層高めることになります。
財政拡大の中で日銀の利上げが後手に回れば、内外金利差が意識され為替しじょうでは一段と円売りが優勢になるのは自然な流れです。
円安による輸入コストの上昇が国内の物価をさらに押し上げる輸入インフレにもかかわらず、政権の姿勢からは円安を抑制しようとする本気度が感じられません。
むしろ、インフレと円安を容認しているのではないかとさえ思ってしまいます。
アメリカ政府は日本の現状の財政金融政策に不満を持っているとされていますが現政権は政策修正する考えが無いようです。
高市政権が現状の政策をどこまで続けることができるのか。
現状の経済政策による金利、為替、そして株価への悪影響を考慮したアセットアロケーションがますます重要です。
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
2　本気でやる資産運用　〜　セミナー・イベントのご案内
将来のお金の不安を解消したい方のための資産設計実践会セミナー＆説明会のご案内
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
3　読者の質問コーナー
読者からのご質問に、内藤忍がズバリ回答いたします！
Ｑ：ソフトバンクの社債が個人投資家に人気のようですが、購入する価値はあるのでしょうか？
Ａ：ご質問ありがとうございます。
ソフトバンクグループが今回発行する社債は償還までの年限が7年で利率は年4.75％。
投資単位は100万円です。
ソフトバンクというブランドに安心感がある上に定期預金や国債よりもずっと利回りが良いというのが人気の理由で、発行額は1兆円になるそうです。
確かに、いっぱんに販売されている他の金融商品と比べれば表面上の利回りは非常に魅力的です。
しかしインフレが進む経済環境下では、実質資産価値を毀損しないために資産をインフレ率を上回る利率で運用していくことが必須です。
投資判断においてはリスクとリターンのバランスを忘れてはいけません。
社債には国債とは異なる発行体企業のデフォルト（債務不履行）リスクが存在します。
7年という長期間に渡り同社の信用リスクを取ることによるリターンとして魅力的かどうかを冷静に判断すべきです。
また日本円建ての社債を購入することは、円資産の比率が固定されることになります。
こんご円安が進行しインフレ率が上昇すれば資産価値にマイナスの影響が出ることも考えられます。
個人的には今回発行される社債は信用リスクや金利上昇・為替動向といった経済環境の変動リスクに対してリターンが見合ったものとは考えられず購入する必要は無いと考えます。
購入する場合は信用リスクの分散を心がけ、集中投資は避けるようにしましょう。
このコーナーでは読者の方からのご質問に、資産デザイン研究所だいひょう取締役の内藤忍がメールマガジン上で回答いたします。
資産デザイン研究所
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
4　内藤忍の「白米ダイエット日記」
焼き鳥を超えた鶏料理の名店
イタリアワインの会が大江戸線の牛込柳町駅のすぐ近くのお店で開催されました。
各自が持ち込んだワインを楽しむ会でしたが、私はワインよりもむしろお店で出された鶏料理のクオリティの高さに目を奪われました。
あまりにおいしく感動したので、その場で予約をして翌日またプライベートで出かけてしまいました。
遅い時間に行ってみると、この日もお店は満席で大繁盛です。
カウンター席からは食鳥しょりの資格を持つ店主が手際よく丸鶏をさばく様子を見ることができ、それぞれの部位に最適な火入れをして順番に食べさせてくれます。
鳥の種類も比内地鶏やホロホロ鳥など全国から選りすぐりのものをセレクトしベストな状態で提供してくれます。
弾力と濃厚な肉旨味が広がるもも肉の炭火焼きや、しっとりと滑らかなレアの火入れが際立つささみなどどれも唸る味わいです。
こちらのお店で鶏肉に合わせるのは日本酒です。
熱燗を勧められたので、お店の方にお願いして選んでもらいましたが、どれもお料理のうま味をさらに引き立ててくれます。
日本酒はあっさりとしたものから徐々に熟成の効いた濃厚なものに切り替わっていき、最高でした。
早い時間はコース料理の提供になり、8時半以降はアラカルトでの注文も可能になります。
ただし、遅い時間に行くと希少部位が売り切れてしまうので早めに行ってコース料理の後で追加注文するのが良いでしょう。
凡庸な焼き鳥店より圧倒的に満足できる素晴らしいお店。
しかもお会計も1人1万円でお釣りがくる良心的プライスでした。
これ以上人気が出て予約が取れないお店にならないことを祈ります。
食鳥 伍ノ捌（しょくちょうごのはち）
東京都新宿区市谷柳町9 DeLCCS市谷柳町 2F
070-1482-5858
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。